Joe Biden can beat Donald Trump if he steps down.
As a lover of democracy and my female bodily autonomy,
nothing makes me more
then admitting that this is the beginning of the end for Joe Biden.
But Joe Biden has the opportunity
to turn his worst moment in his presidency
into his best one. By doing what Lyndon Johnson did in 1968
and step aside
and let credit candidates bat it out at the democratic convention,
Biden could effectively fulfill his promise
of being a transitional figure
and create space for the next person to come in
and put his country first.
And prevent the democracy ending.
Uh, possibility of Trump getting a second term.
And while there's not a lot of viable candidates,
there's not a lot of time before the election.
Like, I recognize,
all of those things are valid.
Joe Biden stepping down right now
would actually also solve a lot of problems.
It means that Democrats could finally go after Trump
for his biggest weakness apart from his 91 convictions,
his age, and his unfitness for office.
Right now, they literally can't do that because, yeah,
Trump is old, but Biden is older.
To have a second Trump presidency
could just have irreversible consequences.
Joe Biden has an opportunity to make his Mark in history.
And opening up the field is risky,
but so is staying in the game.